okay then we're in and this is the
computing center at CERN I mean really
this is the brain of the Large Hadron
Collider
now it's really loud in here it's not a
place where I can easily do interviews
or give you a live commentary so I'm
recording this afterwards but I just
wanted you to see what it looks like and
hear what it sounds like when you walk
through these kind of little corridors
here I can't tell you how hot it is the
hot air is just blasting you from both
sides it's like being in a little oven
and of course it's so loud I mean you
can hardly hear yourself think now this
is really the heart of what CERN calls
the grid which is a network of computer
systems and centers around the world
that's used to process the insane amount
of data produced by the Large Hadron
Collider the LHC produces about 600
million particle collisions our second
and although they don't keep everything
I mean that would be crazy
they just keep a tiny 100,000 snapshots
per second that's still a fair amount of
viously and that means they're storing
about where they're storing over a
thousand megabytes per second and it
makes its way here to the data center
now the data doesn't just need storing
it needs processing and that's where the
grid comes in this Center is the start
of it all and they call it tier zero
it's the tier zero Center then there are
tiers one you get tier twos and you get
tier threes and they're scattered all
over the world together they allow
thousands of physicists to access all
this information and more importantly
crunch all the data process it make
sense of it all and I mean just the tier
0 center here alone does a million jobs
a day and it can transfer up to 10
gigabytes of data every second and I
mean these are just numbers obviously
but when you think about it they're
pretty high numbers now as you can see
here some of these banks some of these
racks of computers are kept in kind of
these glass enclosures I didn't actually
ask about that but I'm assuming it's all
sealed so that it's more easy to to keep
air-conditioned and to keep cool calling
this place is just so important and in
fact here you see
these big blue towers I mean that's part
of the air conditioning system I'm
pretty sure they told me if the cooling
fails everything gets switched off very
quickly otherwise they have bit of a
meltdown I do love that you sort of have
these little keyboards and computers on
the end of the Rex too I mean I mean
it's obvious that your wood but it's
somehow amuses me I'm not sure why I
mean I sometimes think the cables behind
my computer and television are
complicated when I see this place I feel
like my head's going to explode
now we've come upstairs the center's
actually spread over two floors and here
we see the cartridges or tapes that a
lot of the information stored on one of
the storage units here for the tapes was
actually being worked on while I was
there so the door was open and I could
have a look inside now often when the
information on these tapes is accessed
there's kind of this robotic sort of a
device type thing that scurries around
the racks and pulls out the tapes and
whenever I wasn't filming it would go
whizzing around doing all this cool
stuff but as soon as I started filming
it all kind of stopped and I had to wait
for ages but I was determined to show
you one in action and eventually
eventually I've managed to get this
you get the idea okay now we've come up
to a little sort of room where you can
see over the center this is the
ground-floor part of the center again
you can see how high the ceiling is
that's actually not a good thing modern
data centers actually have low ceilings
I think it's because it's easier to cool
the rooms if the rooms are smaller but
this was built at a time when well
computers were a lot bigger it's
actually in a lot of ways the building
in the rooms quite outdated for the
purpose but they're still using it I
think it's certain they prefer spending
their money on a new kit rather than new
buildings and they're still doing a
pretty good job and here's one last
thing I want to show you it's actually
outside the computer center they call
this the soon animal shelter for
computer mice it's bit of a joke but
it's where the it's where the computer
mice go to retire when they're then no
longer in use is mice the plural where
the mouse's must be mice anyway there it
is it's a bit of fun now as I said it
was remarkably loud in the center so it
wasn't really easy to do interviews but
I did do interviews with people that
work here at the computer centre you're
going to be able to see them very soon
here on computer file Sean who I work
with is going to be having all that
going through all adding it together
soon so stay tuned for that also while
we were at CERN we made a music video
for the sixty symbols channel if you
haven't seen that yet go and have a look
it was a bit of fun and I also recorded
something about the corridor where the
World Wide Web was developed and that
video is already on computer file so you
can go and check that out too there's so
much to look at thanks for watching this
and we hope to see you soon for more
videos